[Music]
it's a tuesday edition of pft ot just
six days until pft live is back on nbc
sports radio and nbc sn plenty of things
still happening though in the nfl
training camps opening and the nfl
taking care of business on friday we
found out that chief's receiver tyrek
hill would not be suspended as a result
of multiple potential violations of the
personal conduct policy for which he was
investigated coincidentally or not the
nfl held until the next business day the
news that seahawks defensive lineman
geron reid would be suspended six games
under the personal conduct policy even
though he wasn't arrested wasn't charged
but the nfl decided he had violated the
personal conduct policy as a result of a
domestic violence incident now the
problem with this
and this really speaks to the heart of
the nfl's investigative procedures and
the power the nfl has or more accurately
doesn't have to get the information that
it needs in reed's case i'm told that
the alleged victim cooperated with the
nfl if the victim says i'm not
cooperating good luck getting the
information that you need in order to
come to the conclusion that a violation
of the personal conduct policy has
occurred and that's what happened in
hill's case because the underlying child
abuse investigation involves a minor
there's an exception to the open records
law in kansas and the johnson county
kansas prosecutor was able to tell the
nfl we're not giving you any evidence
we're not giving you any documents so
the nfl had no opportunity to delve into
the details as to what did or didn't
happen and who was or wasn't suspected
and remember the prosecutor in tyreek
hill's case said back in april that he
believes a crime was committed against
tyra kill's three-year-old son the
prosecutor just didn't believe he could
prove who actually did it so there's
evidence there somewhere of something
happening to this child but in hill's
case the nfl couldn't get to it
in jaron reid's case the nfl could and i
think that
more than anything else should prompt
the nfl to take a step back and say
why are we doing this why are we trying
to be our own police force and justice
system when we lack the powers of a
police force or justice system it's one
thing if you're investigating wrongdoing
among nfl employees or team employees
and there's a way to compel people who
are on the payroll to cooperate but they
have no power over people who are
disconnected from the nfl and that's why
there was such a discrepancy between
hill and reed and i think that's why the
nfl held reed's decision held the news
of the suspension until monday it would
have been too glaring if it had come out
on the same day that we found out that
tyree kill was not going to be suspended
we are awaiting word that julio jones
and the atlanta falcons have a long-term
contract in place i continue to hear
that people within the league believe
that there's a deal already in place and
they're waiting for the one year
anniversary of last year's contract
adjustment last year was july 26th this
year july 26 or thereafter look for
julio jones to get his new contract now
other receivers waiting to see what
their colleagues may be getting waiting
to see what jones gets waiting to see
what michael thomas gets waiting to see
what others get and that may be why
amari cooper the cowboys receiver but
reportedly in no hurry to do a long-term
deal in dallas another reason he's in no
hurry
unlike some of these younger receivers
like tyree kill and michael thomas who
are making low money relatively speaking
in the fourth year of their contracts
cooper is in that option year and he was
a top 10 pick he's getting more than 13
million in salary this year he's got all
the leverage he can sit back and wait
and remember
we made this point several
months ago to the chagrin of cowboys
fans who don't like us stirring up ideas
for their players who can come together
and say to the team and this is what
amari cooper and dak prescott could say
we're not signing a contract until after
next year's deadline for the franchise
tag you will tag one of us and the other
one will become a free agent and between
cooper and prescott chances are it's
prescott who would be tagged and cooper
would then become a free agent but you
know he's going to carry the injury risk
for one more year but there's an upside
waiting for amari cooper and that's
ultimately why he has no problem waiting
for that long term deal
tom brady's still waiting for his next
long-term deal or as the case may be a
short-term deal he's in the final season
of the latest team-friendly contract
that he did with the patriots and it
always makes me laugh to call it team
friendly because he usually gets a
gigantic pile of money up front last
time around it was a 30 million signing
bonus but still
annual average far below what the best
quarterbacks in the nfl are making and
it was reported by nfl media on monday
that there's no extension in sight for
brady now he's got the same
quirk that applies to julio jones they
have to wait one year
after last year's
adjustment that was done by tom brady
remember last year he was given the
opportunity to earn up to five million
dollars in incentives based on five
different categories and it was a
million per category and he ultimately
hit
none
of those triggers so he got no extra
money last year even though the patriots
were trying to give it to him and look
after this year he becomes a free agent
now the patriots presumably would apply
the franchise tag if they want to keep
him around but
you you just have to wonder what kind of
late career contractual acrimony could
ultimately happen between the patriots
and brady especially because there's a
persistent belief and tom curran of nbc
sports boston is the one who clued me in
on this that brady wants to get paid as
much or more
than his former understudy jimmy
garoppolo garoppolo is making 27.5
million per year in san francisco brady
making far less than that andrew luck is
making less than 25 million per year he
was not that long ago the highest paid
player in the nfl but more and more
quarterbacks have leapfrogged him and
it's hard for him to complain that he's
underpaid because he's been injured for
much of the last
couple of years but last season he was
healthy last season he was effective and
now heading into training camp that calf
problem that knocked him out for a lot
of the offseason program apparently
resolved he's good to go he's ready to
go but keep an eye on it because if it's
not fully and truly 100 it can get
aggravated easily any type of
muscle injury in the legs hamstring quad
calf
once it grabs
if it isn't completely and totally
healed it can grab again and it can be a
problem throughout the entire season for
andrew luck so here's hoping that he
won't be limited by that and the colts
are in position if he's healthy to build
on the success that they had
unexpectedly in 2018. i mentioned
jimmy garoppolo a few minutes ago
and the 49ers hold all the cards when it
comes to garoppolo's future after this
year for one very important reason the
49ers have been using for at least the
last five years a
a device in how they structure their
contracts that delays the vesting of
guarantees until april the first of each
year now other teams either have
guarantees become fully vested right
after the start of the waiver period in
february or right after the start of the
league year in march by delaying until
april 1 the san francisco 49ers give
themselves an opportunity to look at all
options they can explore anything and
everything that they would otherwise
potentially do at quarterback whether
it's trade for someone whether it's sign
a free agent whether it's do as much due
diligence as possible on the incoming
class of rookies if they finish high
enough in the draft order and in turn
low enough in the standings to get
themselves in position for one of the
top incoming quarterbacks and meanwhile
you have until april 1 to make that
decision on what you're going to do with
jimmy garoppolo so that contractual
structure waiting until april 1 to have
the guarantees fully vest works to the
benefit of the team and i'm talking
about that today because agent doug
hendrickson
really the first agent to publicly call
out the 49ers for using that contract
structure calling it bs although he
didn't say bs plenty of agents have been
complaining about it privately over the
years and no one's really taken a stand
you know the 49ers say this is the way
we do our deals and what happens is the
agents just go along with it because
here's the thing
if you don't take the money someone else
will
and someone else will agree to that
structure and until the agents and the
nflpa come together and say we reject
this structure the 49ers are going to
continue to do it the amazing thing is
other teams haven't used that structure
it's just the 49ers and it does give
them more flexibility than other teams
have when deciding whether or not to
keep a guy who's got some guaranteed
money that's about to fully vest and it
vests on april 1 and before april 1 of
2020 it could be the 49ers decide to
move on from jimmy garoppolo i'm going
to move on until the next pftot no show
if this really is a show i don't know
what this is but no edition of pftot
on wednesday we'll be back on thursday
we'll do another one on friday and then
comes the triumphant or otherwise return
of pft live next monday have a great day
check us out around the clock at
profootballtalk.com and we'll talk to
you on thursday
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports